a sólo 200 kilómetros separan a estos
soldados franceses de un país en guerra
están en esta base militar de la otan en
rumanía reforzando el flanco oriental de
la alianza donde las repercusiones del
conflicto en ucrania se han sentido con
especial fuerza en rumanía más como
visitará a los cerca de 500 soldados
franceses estacionados en la base
militar donde francia también ha
desplegado un sistema de misiles
tierra-aire
hay un gran sentimiento de solidaridad
entre nosotros
el espíritu que nos une como soldados es
igual al de la otan
funcionarios del palacio el elíseo dicen
que el objetivo de maco es subrayar el
compromiso de francia con la otan más
tarde se dirigirá a moldavia uno de los
países más pobres de europa que se
enfrenta a una afluencia masiva de
refugiados francia está proporcionando
moldavia apoyo financiero para ayudarle
a hacer frente a esta crisis
más de 400.000 personas han huído el
país desde ucrania aunque muchos se han
trasladado a rumanía unos 80.000 han
decidido quedarse en moldavia
la gran pregunta que planea sobre el
viaje de macon es si acabara con una
visita a ucrania el presidente francés
es uno de los pocos líderes europeos que
aún no han pisado dicho territorio desde
la invasión rusa y por ahora es una
visita que no ha sido descartada por los
funcionarios franceses